ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBERAND BRINGING OUT
THE MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL WE ARE CURRY. RAMBOVA
BARRICADE HAND BENNETT BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BURNER HORA BONTA
BURKE CALDERONE RIO SERVAN
TESTS SHOW JUNE TO CHOI COOLLY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DAILY DAVIES
FLORA PHONE FRASIER FREEDMAN
GABRIEL GALLAGHER CHRISTINA
GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA GIBSON
GONZALEZ GRAY. GRAYSON HOLDEN-
WHEN JONES SAWYER KALRA M.
LONGER KYLIE BLACKY LEE LEVIN
LOW MADE SHINE MAP THIS MAZE
MCCARTY MEDINA MOLLEN RESEARCH.
THIS AREA WHEN O'DONNELL
PATTERSON THREE DOORS QUIRK
MARK SILVA RAMEAU'S RAY IS
LOOSE THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SOLACE SANTIAGO
SAY ARTURO SMITH. STONE TEAM
ELDERS VIA PUJA BOBO WELL
YOU'RE IN WAR. WEBER WICKS WORD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER IN THE GALLERY
TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY FAMILY MEMBERS ON. THE
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
PRAYER. THE GOD OF HOPE EVEN IN
THE MIDST OF SO MUCH TURMOIL
TRAGEDY IN TEARS YOU ARE IN
CONTROL OF ALL THINGS. LORD WE
CONFESS OUR NEED AND CALL TO
YOU FOR HELP WE ASK THAT YOU
PROVIDE US WITH DISCERNING
HEART. COMPASSION FOR THOSE WHO
SUFFER PEACE BEYOND OUR
UNDERSTANDING AND THE MEANS TO
SHARE YOUR LOVING KINDNESS WITH
OUR NEIGHBORS. THAT PASSWORD IN
OUR WEAKNESS YOU GIVE US
STRENGTH. GIVE US THE STRENGTH
TO FORGIVE ONE ANOTHER AS YOU
HAVE FORGIVEN US FOR TRESPASS
AGAINST YOU. AS A NATION WE ARE
DEEP IN DEEPLY TROUBLING TIME.
BUT WE CAN PLACE OUR TRUST IN
YOUR ABUNDANT GRACE TO RESTORE
TO US PEACE AND UNITY. AS WE
REFLECT ANDRE EXAMINE OUR OWN
HEARTS. GIVE EACH OF US THE
HUMILITY TO RECOGNIZE THAT WE
DO NOT HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS.
BUT THAT YOU GRANT WISDOM TO
THOSE WHO ASK. AS WE GATHER
TOGETHER TO WORK ON BEHALF OF
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. MAY
WE WORK AND REFLECT IN YOUR
SPIRIT OF TRUTH AND LOVE. MAY
WE SEEK TO ACCOMPLISH NOT ARE
WELL BUT YOUR PERFECT WILL IN
ALL THAT WE DO IN YOUR NAME WE
PRAY AMEN. I THINK YOUR FAMILY
MEMBER FOUND WE ASK OUR GUESTS
TO VISITORS REMAIN STANDING IN
JOIN US IN THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN FAMILY MEMBER
GRAYSON IF HE LEAVES US IN THE
FIGHT. CALLING PLEASE JOIN IN
THE PLEDGE. I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED
STATES- YEAH. THANK YOU YOU MAY
BE SEATED. THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL. GOLDEN
ONE CENTER SACRAMENTO MONDAY
DECEMBER SEVENTH. IN THIS WATER
IN SECOND AT THE READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. VISITATIONS AND
PETITIONS THERE ARE NINE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE THE
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED. REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AN AMENDMENT INTERRUPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE
MOVING TO MOTION THE
RESOLUTION. TODAY'S ABSENCES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL. THIS RESCUE ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. MADAM
SPEAKER. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AG WE
ARE CURRY ROMMEL'S SAY OUR TOE
IN MEDINA TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SAID SHOW ME
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO SIMPLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO REFER THE
FOLLOWING BILL TO COMMITTEE. AB
SEVENTY ONE LUZ RIVAS FROM THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE TO THE
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
AND THEN BACK TO THE HOUSING
AND COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION
SPECIALTY ORDER. MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE C. R.
TWO THE CLERK WILL READ. AS OF
THE CURRENT RESOLUTION TO BUY
SOME RECORDS AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO KOREAN AMERICAN DAY.
MS CLARK SILVER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS RESOLUTION.
HELLO MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT TO SOMEBODY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TO KOREAN AMERICAN
DAY. AS A MEMBER OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY DELEGATION I AM PROUD TO
HONOR THE KOREAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY FOR KERMIT RIAN
AMERICAN DAY. IN NINETEEN OH
THREE A HUNDRED INTO COURAGEOUS
KOREAN MEN WOMEN AND CHILDREN
pVENTURING ACROSS THE VAST
PACIFIC OCEAN ABOARD THE SS
GAELIC. IT WOULD BE ANOTHER
FOUR YEARS BEFORE THESE
FAMILIES ABOUT ONE THOUSAND
KOREAN AMERICANS ENTERED THE
MAINLAND UNITED STATES THROUGH
SAN FRANCISCO. DESPITE SOCIAL
ECONOMIC AND LANGUAGE BARRIERS
OF ON SO MORE UNFORESEEN
MAGNITUDE THERE CHRIS PURSUIT
OF THE AMERICAN DREAM WAS
UNWAVERING. CALIFORNIA IS NOW
HOME TO MORE KOREAN AMERICANS
THAN ANY OTHER STATE. A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN YEARS LATER WE
CONTINUE TO CELEBRATE THE
BRAVERY OF THESE INCREDIBLE
INDIVIDUALS WITH KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY. THERE ARE MANY
STORIES OF PERSONAL AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL SUCCESS AND
PARTICULARLY IN MY DISTRICT
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT SIXTY FIVE.
BUSINESSES ARE FLOURISHING AND
GROWING AND NEARLY ONE IN EVERY
FIVE MEMBERS OF OUR KOREAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY ARE SELF
EMPLOYED AND WORKING. ATR TO
SPEAKS TO THE RICH HISTORY OF
PEOPLE IN SEARCH OF OPPORTUNITY
AND FREEDOM TO THOSE WHO WANTED
TO MAKE A BETTER LIFE FOR THEIR
FAMILIES HAPPY KOREAN AMERICAN
DAY. THANK YOU MISS QUIRK SILVA.
MR CHOI YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON
THIS RESOLUTION. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS SAW
A- RISE- TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF OUR A. C. R. O. TWO
IN COMMEMORATION OF THE KOREAN
AMERICAN DAY AND THAT THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SHARON QUIRK
SILVA FOR JOINT AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT ANNUAL OR RESOLUTION
NOT WITH ME. ARE YOU USUALLY
HAVE A RECEPTION- INVITING ALL
OF YOU TO- TASTES AS SOME
KOREAN FOOD AND THEN ALSO- LOSS
OF- KOREAN COMMUNITY LEADERS
OUT UP IN THE BALCONY AND
TYPICAL LEADERS ABOUT- THIS
YEAR- CORBETT HAS PREVENTED BUT
THIS SPIRIT. LIVE SONG AND- WE
HAD- ZOOM CELEBRATION ON ON
WEDNESDAY ON THE DAY OF A
JANUARY THIRTEENTH- AS YOU'LL
HAVE HEARD ALREADY THOUGH A
BRIEF HISTORY- TODAY IS-
SIXTEENTH. OF KOREAN AMERICAN
DAY CELEBRATION ON- SINCE- D.
U. S. CONGRESS. A PASSIVE
RESOLUTION. ASKING A JAN THIRD
AT UP OR AMERICAN DAY INDY ON
STATES SO BUT THE SAW MARK ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THE- ALL YEAR
SO- THE GROUP- IMAGE. HAS SAW A
RIDE IN HAWAII IN A NINETEEN
OH. THREE AND- WE- SINCE THERE
HAVE A COUNTRY TO IN MANY
SECTORS OF THE INDUSTRY
INCLUDING OUR POLITICS- MYSELF
AND THAT THIS YEAR- WE HAVE
ADDED THE ONE MORE KOREAN
AMERICAN AT THE SENATE. OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE DAVID
MANN AND I'M SURE THEY ARE
HORSE OWNERS CELEBRATING AT THE
SENATE FLOOR AS WELL AND THE A.
C. R. A. A TWO IS IN
RECOGNIZING THAT THEY ARE TO
GET THE END OF EACH YEAR YOU
HAVE A CELEBRATED WITH US SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR. ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR CHOI PLAYING IN
HEARING FURTHER ON THE MATTER
THIS WORK ALTHOUGH DO I TO
CLOSE. THIS WORK HELLO DO
PERSONAL FOR CAUGHT. YES I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY TO.
AND ASKED YOU TO JOIN ME FOR CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU CLARK WELL
OPEN THE ROLE. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS SUNNY C. R. TO ALL
MEMBERS OF THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON
A C. R. TWO. ALL MEMBERS THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. THIS IS FOR
CO AUTHORS. THE CLERK WELL
CLOSE THE ROLLING TALLY THAT
THERE ARE SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS
ANY C. R. TWO WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
EASIER TO ALL IN FAVOR SAY AYE.
ALL OPPOSED SAY NO THE AYES
HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO
A C. R. EIGHT THE CLERK WILL
READ. SO WE CURRENTLY EIGHT BY
SIN REMEMBER WEBER AND OTHERS
RELATIVE REVENUE DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR. MISTER
MCCARTY YOU ARE RECOGNIZED OPEN
ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF OUR
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
SUPPORTED AC ARE EIGHT. TO
HONOR. AGAIN TODAY IS TO HONOR
THE A BIRTHDAY THE NINETY
SECOND BIRTHDAY OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND RECOGNIZE THIS
IMPORTANT HOLIDAY IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IN CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA IS OF COURSE THE
FIRST STATE TO RECOGNIZE AND
CELEBRATE THE LIFE OF DR KING.
AND AS WE REFLECT ABOUT DR KING
AT TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHICH I
THINK ABOUT HOW FAR WE CUT WE
HAVE COME BUT ALSO HOW FAR WE
NEED TO GO. LET'S JUST THINK
ABOUT THE LAST THE LAST THE
LAST WEEK AS WE REMEMBER DR
KING AND THINK ABOUT. THE
HOLIDAY WHEN WE THINK ABOUT.
REMEMBRANCE AND SERVICE
HOPEFULLY NEXT WEEK DURING THE
DURING THE DAY OFTEN MANY OF US
ARE TAKING THE DAY OFF IT'S
REALLY ABOUT REFLECTION. BUT
AGAIN LET'S THINK ABOUT HIS
LEGACY THE PAST. TEN DAYS. WE
ARE AMAZED LAST TUESDAY NIGHT.
WHEN WE SAW THE AMAZING
ELECTORAL VICTORY. A REFERENDUM
RAPHAELWARNOCK THE POT THE
PASTOR OF DR KING'S EBENEZER
BAPTIST CHURCH. HE BECAME
GEORGIA'S FIRST BLACK SENATOR.
TRULY AMAZING IN THE DEEP
SOUTH. AND REMARKABLE SHOWING
US HOW FAR WE HAVE COME. DR
KING WOULD SURELY BE BEAMING
FROM PRIDE. AS DR WARNOCK
NOTED. HIS MOM USED TO PICK
COTTON. AND THAT DAY TEN DAYS
AGO HIS MOM WAS ABLE TO PICK
WHO WOULD BECOME THE U. S.
SENATOR FROM GEORGIA. BUT WE
ALL KNOW WHAT HAPPENED THE VERY
NEXT DAY. WHEN A MOB OF RIDERS
FILLED WITH HATE. AND WHITE
SUPREMACY. STORMED OUR NATION'S
CAPITAL. THAT WAS NOT NINETEEN
SIXTY ONE. THAT WAS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WITH THAT SINK IN
FOR A MOMENT AS WE THINK ABOUT
DR KING IN THE HOLIDAY. WE SAW
OVER TWO DAYS THE BEST OF US.
AND THE WORST OF US. IT'S A
CLEAR REMINDER THAT DR KING'S
WORK IS NOT DONE. WE KNOW THIS
AND WE KNOW AS WE CELEBRATE AND
HONOR THIS NATIONAL HOLIDAY WE
LOOK ABOUT THE MOMENTS OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BEEN
REINVIGORATED THE MOVEMENT OF
DR KING IN THE NINETEEN
SIXTIES. A MOMENT OF RACIAL
JUSTICE ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS OUR COUNTRY. THE SUMMER
OF TWENTY TWENTY DOT
CALIFORNIANS RISE UP AFTER THE
MURDER OF GEORGE FLOYD WITH AN
INDOMITABLE QUEST TO CONTINUE
DR KING'S WORK. THIS PAST YEAR
WE TOOK A LONG LOOK INWARD AND
CONTINUE TO LOOK AT OURSELVES
ASKING OURSELVES KEY QUESTIONS.
HAVE WEDONE ENOUGH TO HONOR DR
KING'S WORK WHAT ELSE CAN WE DO.
WE KNOW THIS THE WEEK THAT WE
HAVE MORE WORK TO DO WE KNOW
THE ARC OF JUSTICE DENSE. WE
KNOW WE CAN EITHER HELP OR
HINDER. CERTAINLY WE'RE PROUD
THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
RISE UP AND HONOR DR KING'S
LEGACY WITH OUR WORK JUST IN
THE PAST TWO YEARS WE'VE
ENACTED MAJOR POLICE REFORM
MEASURES RESTORED VOTING
RIGHTS. DOWN THE SCHOOL TO
PRISON PIPELINE AND LAUNCHED
WEEK IN THE WEEKS TO COME WE
MUST TO KEEP CONTINUE TO GET
OUT OF THE WORK OF MAKING AN
HONORING DR KING'S LEGACY WITH
ACTION VOTES AND MAKING TOUGH
CHOICES. WE MUST REMEMBER THE
REASON WHY WE HONOR AND
CELEBRATE DR KING HIS SPIRIT IN
LIFE CREATE A PIVOTAL MOMENT IN
OUR NATION'S HISTORY. EMOTE A
MOVEMENT AND M. AND MOMENTS TO
TRANSFORM THE LIVES OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS BUT CLEARLY WERE NOT
DONE. LET'S REFLECT ON THE
WORDS OF DR KING AS WE EMBARK
ON OUR WORK IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. I REMEMBER THE TIME IS
ALWAYS RIGHT. TO DO WHAT IS
RIGHT. MEMBERS I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT HAVE A C. R. EIGHT. AND
MADAM SPEAKER ANNOUNCED THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN TO CO
AUTHORS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER MCCARTY MISREAD MENU ARE
RECOGNIZED ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU MADAM THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. IT'S WITH GREAT PRIDE
THAT I RISE TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE
JEWISH CAUCUS. IN SUPPORT OF A
C. R. EIGHT AND TO CELEBRATE
THE EXTRAORDINARY LIFE AND
LEGACY OF DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR. THE JEWISH CAUCUS IS
HUMBLED TO STAND ON THE
SHOULDERS OF SUCH A GIANT AS DR
KING. WHOSE TEACHINGS AND WORDS
CONTINUE TO PIERCE THROUGH THE
DARKEST OF TIMES FOR ALL
MARGINALIZED MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES FOREIGN AND
DOMESTIC. LAST YEAR MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED THE SPECIAL
PLACE THAT IS FOREVER CARVED
OUT IN THE HEARTS AND MINDS OF
AMERICAN JEWS FOR DR KING. I
WOULD LIKE TO PAY FOR YOU
TODAY. THE IMAGE OF ONE
THOUSAND RABBIS DURING A
CELEBRATION THAT THE REVEREND
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
ATTENDED IN CELEBRATION. OF
BELOVED RABBI ABRAHAM. JOSHUA
HERSHEL IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. IN HEBREW AND IN
SOLIDARITY THEY SANG WE SHALL
OVERCOME. AND COLLEAGUES I
CANNOT THINK OF A MORE TIMELY
SONG TITLE FOR OUR NATION. WE
SHALL OVERCOME THESE TRYING
TIMES BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD THE
PLEASURE OF LEARNING HOW TO
RESPECT AND HOW TO LOVE EACH
OTHER FROM DR KING. HIS
POWERFUL MENTION MET MENTIONED
MESSAGE OF EQUALITY AND JUSTICE
ARE ALSO THE CORNERSTONES OF MY
JEWISH FAITH IN OUR TRADITION.
IN FACT THE CONCEPT OF TWO CAME
ALONG. WHICH MEANS TO HEAL THE
WORLD IS EMBODIED BY ALL OF DR
KING'S ACTIONS AND BY HIS
LEGACY. AND ON THIS DAY THAT WE
REMEMBER DR KING I'D BE REMISS
IF I DID NOT MENTION THE POWER
OF HOPE. THAT HE HAS PROVIDED
FOR ALL GENERATIONS THAT HAVE
FOLLOWED HIM. WE MUST ACCEPT
FINITE DISAPPOINTMENT BUT NEVER
LOSE INFINITE HOPE THOSE WERE
HIS WORDS AND AS WE ENTER A NEW
YEAR. I IMPLORE ALL OF US TO
NEVER LOSE INFINITE HOPE. SO
THAT WE MAY CONTINUE TO HONOR
ADVANCE THE BETTER TOMORROW.
THAT DR KING HAD HOPED FOR ALL
OF US. THIS WEEKEND LET US
REMEMBER DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR'S VISION OF LOVE. ZERO
AND BELIEF IN FREEDOM AND
JUSTICE AND HIS HOPE FOR A
BETTER TOMORROW. HE WAS AS WE
SAY. A REAL MENSCH IN THAT
SPIRIT I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A C. R. EIGHT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN
MYSTERY OF US YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER- ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. I ALSO RISE TODAY TO
HONOR THE LEGACY OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR. IN NINETEEN
SIXTY SIX WITH DR KING WROTE A
LETTER TO SETTLE CHAVEZ WHO HAD
RECENTLY MARCH FROM DELANO TO
SACRAMENTO IT WAS NEARLY THREE
HUNDRED MILE WALK. HE HAD
MARCHED TO BRING ATTENTION TO
THE MISTREATMENT OF FARM
WORKERS. IN HIS LETTER IT WAS
DR KING STATED AS BROTHERS IN
THE FIGHT FOR EQUALITY. I STILL
HAD A FELLOWSHIP AND GOOD WILL
IN WHICH THE CONTINUING SUCCESS
TO YOU AND YOUR MEMBERS. OUR
SEPARATE STRUGGLES ARE REALLY
ONE. A STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM FOR
DIGNITY FOR HUMANITY. THE
DOCTOR KING SO CLEARLY THAT NO
ONE CAN BE FREE UNLESS WE ALL
ARE FREE. BUT NO ONE COULD HAVE
JUSTICE UNLESS WE ALL HAVE
JUSTICE. OVER THE PAST YEAR WE
HAVE SEEN A PANDEMIC THAT HAS
DEVASTATED OUR VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. MANY OF THEM BROWN
AND BLACK. WE HAVE SEEN A
MOVEMENT FOR RACIAL JUSTICE.
FOR EQUAL TREATMENT UNDER THE
LAW. AND NOW WE ARE THREATENED.
BY WHITE SUPREMACISTS BY
CONSPIRACY THEORISTS. WHO
REJECT OUR DEMOCRATIC
TRADITIONS. TRADITIONS OF
NONVIOLENT PROTEST. A PEACEFUL
TRANSFERS OF POWER. OF REASONED
DEBATE. THE DEBATE BASED ON
FACTS AND FREE OF VIOLENCE.
THESE ARE THE TRADITIONS THAT
ALLOW US TO EXIST TOGETHER AS A
NATION. THAT ALLOW US TO MOVE
SLOWLY AND IN PERFECTLY.
TOWARDS LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR
ALL. IN HIS LETTER FROM A
BIRMINGHAM JAIL DOCTOR KING
SAID IT AGAIN. WE ARE CAUGHT IN
AN INESCAPABLE NETWORK TIED TO
A SINGLE GARMENT OF DESTINY.
I'M SO PROUD TO SERVE ALONGSIDE
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE BLACK
CAUCUS. I'M PROUD TO SERVE
ALONGSIDE EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU. AND IN MY CAPACITY AS VICE
CHAIR AS A MEMBER OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS. I RECOMMIT TODAY. TO
HONOR THE VALUES OF DR KING. TO
WORK FOR JUSTICE. TO EXTENDED A
HAND OF FELLOWSHIP AND GOOD
WILL. AND TO RECOGNIZE AS DR
KING WROTE THAT OUR SEPARATE
STRUGGLES ARE REALLY ONE. THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH MADAM SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MR THIS MISTER Q. ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU ON BEHALF
OF THE LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS I WRITE IN SUPPORT OF A
C. R. E. DR KING'S LEGACY IS
ROOTED IN THE FIGHT OF THE
QUALITY AND THE FIGHT AGAINST
INJUSTICE FOR NONVIOLENCE.
HONORING HIS MEMORY WITH THIS
RESOLUTION DURING A TIME OF
SUCH CIVIL UNREST IT'S RAINING.
IF DR KING WERE HERE TODAY TO
WITNESS THE STATE OF AMERICA
TODAY I IMAGINE HE WOULD NOTE
THAT WHILE THE FLAMES OF
DIVISION ARE BURNING HOT RIGHT
NOW. THEY BURN FROM THE FUEL OF
PROGRESS. THE VIOLENCE WE
WITNESS AGAINST OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AGAINST DEMOCRACY
ARE THE CRY OF A DYING INEQUITY.
ALL OF THE VIOLENCE IN REGIONS
LIKE THE SHOOTING OF A
CONDITION THAT OUR SOCIETY CAN
NO LONGER BEAR. DR KING WOULD
ENCOURAGE US TO SEEK JUSTICE
AND PEACE. THROUGH NONVIOLENCE
EDUCATION AND THROUGH THE POWER
OF OUR FEARS AS WEAPONS THE
BALANCE. THESE LAST YEARS HAVE
BEEN SOME OF THE MOST DIVISIVE
TIMES IN HISTORY. WE HAVE SEEN
SOME OF THE WORST IN OUR
SOCIETY BECAUSE WE HAVE A LOT
OF HATE AND FEAR AND ANGER AND
IGNORANCE TO FLOW FULLY THAT
FREELY AMONG US. AS WITH
DIVISION WIND. DR KING KNEW.
THAT WE NEEDED LOVE AND WISDOM
AND COMPASSION TOWARD ONE
ANOTHER. AND A FEELING OF
JUSTICE TOWARD THOSE WHO STILL
SUFFER WITHIN OUR COUNTRY. AND
IF PAINFUL AS IT MAY BE FOR
SOME OF US DID NOT THAT THAT
TENANT. WHEN IT IS SO EASY TO
SPEAK ILL OF SOMEONE WHO ANGERS
US OR IGNORE THE OPINIONS OF
THOSE WE DISAGREE WITH BECAUSE
IT'S EASY. WE ALL KNOW IN OUR
HEART IT'S RIGHT. LOVE WISDOM
COMPASSION JUSTICE SIMPLE WORDS
TO UNDERSTAND BUT DIFFICULT TO
PUT INTO PRACTICE. I LEARNED
MANY OF THESE LESSONS IN CHURCH
AND SCHOOL DEALING WITH FRIENDS
AND BEING WITH FAMILY MY
PARENTS WORK TO INSTILL THESE
VALUES IN ME AND I STRIVE TO DO
THE SAME FOR MY DAUGHTER. EVERY
DAY. MY MOM SHOWED ME HOW TO
LEAD AND WORK FOR THE COMMUNITY
AND DOING SO. SHE WORKED TO
BRING ABOUT EQUALITY AND A
POSITIVE CHANGE. AND I LEARNED
THAT'S HOW WE SHOW OUR LOVE AND
OUR COMPASSION FOR OUR BROTHERS
AND SISTERS. I BELIEVE IN THAT
MISSION SO MUCH THAT I FOLLOWED
IN HER FOOTSTEPS AND I STAND
BEFORE YOU AS AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. JUST AS SHE WANTS TO.
AN I. BEAM WITH PRIDE AND HONOR
AT THIS DISTINCTION. THAT WE
SHARE IN THIS CHAMBER. BUT AT
THE SAME TIME. I LOOK AT YOU
ALL AND I DON'T SEE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT LOOK LIKE ME. WE
KNOW THE PHRASE REPRESENTATION
MATTERS AND I BELIEVE IN IT
WHOLEHEARTEDLY. I THINK CARLA
HARRIS A BI RACIAL CALIFORNIAN
NATIVE WHO LOOKS LIKE ME REACH
THE WHITE HOUSE'S VICE
PRESIDENT IN NINE STATES BEFORE
YOU EVER BE ETCHED IN MY MEMORY.
I WATCHED HER ASCENT TO HEIGHTS
PREVIOUSLY UNKNOWN BY WOMEN OF
COLOR. I PRAY ISABELLA MY
DAUGHTER GOES TO SEE SOMETHING
LIKE THIS. AND IT'S NOT AN
EXCEPTION. I AM HUMBLED BY DR
KING'S LEGACY AND HIS VISION
FOR OUR NATION. BUT I MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT BEING IN THIS
CHAMBER WHERE WE DO THE
PEOPLE'S WORK. IS A STARK
REMINDER THAT WE STILL HAVE A
WAYS TO GO. WE TALK ABOUT
INCLUSION AND EQUITY. AND
EQUALITY AND JUSTICE AND ONE
WAY TO FULFILL THOSE GOALS IS
TO UPLIFT WOMEN. PEOPLE OF
COLOR. AND THOSE IN
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES AND
OTHERS. I WOULD LOVE TO SEE
THAT REPRESENTATION HERE.
INSTEAD I'M FACED WITH
DWINDLING NUMBERS. AS SADLY
SOON I WILL BE ONE OF THE FEW
BLACK WOMEN IN THIS ASSEMBLY.
BUT I'M NOT DETERRED AND I
BELIEVE DR KING'S DREAM DOES
CONTINUE. AS WE HONOR HIS
MEMORY TODAY LET'S FIND WAYS TO
MAKE THIS BUILDING OUR STATE
OUR NATION ONE OF EQUITY AND
JUSTICE FOR EVERYONE. AND LET
US REMEMBER. WE NOW AND HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN BETTER TO GET.
THANK YOU MISS BURKE. MR WELL
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
RESOLUTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES
SAID ARISE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LGBTQ PLUS CAUCUS AS
WELL AS THE ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS A
WE STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO. HAS SPOKEN VERY
ELOQUENTLY AND SUPPORT AND
RECOGNITION THAT WE TOO SEE YOU
AND THAT WE TO HEAR YOU AND
THAT WE STAND AN ALLY SHIP FOR
THE UNCONDITIONAL AND
UNWAVERING SUPPORT OF A QUALITY
WHICH IS SYNONYMOUS WITH THE
LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. SIMILARLY
WE TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE WHAT IS THE MEANING
OF THE HOLIDAY. WHY SHOULD WE
TAKE TIME OFF. TO RECOGNIZE AN
OKAY DAY. TO REAFFIRM OUR
COMMITMENT AND TO REMEMBER. THE
STRUGGLES IN THE DARK HISTORY
BUT TO CREATE A PATH FORWARD
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS TO COME.
TO BE REMINDED ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF WHAT HIS LEGACY
MEANT FOR ALL OF US NOT JUST IN
TERMS OF SOCIAL JUSTICE BUT
ALSO IN CIVIL RIGHTS. AND AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW AND OKAY ALSO.
ADVOCATED FOR THE ABOLITION. A
POVERTY PERMISSION TO READ
BENEFITS WITHOUT OBJECTION AND
ADVOCATING FOR BASIC MINIMUM
GUARANTEE WHAT WE WOULD THINK
TO TODAY AS AN UNIVERSAL BASIC
INCOME THE TIME HAS COME FOR US
TO CIVILIZE OURSELVES BY THE
TOTAL DIRECT AND IMMEDIATE
ABOLITION OF POVERTY. AND SO WE
SEE SIMILAR ITERATIONS OF A
MINIMUM GUARANTEED INCOME. AND
SO AGAIN WE STAND IN SUPPORT OF
RECOGNIZING. THE LEGACY AND THE
CONTINUATION. OF THE WORK THAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR LOWE SEEING
AND HEARING NO FURTHER DEBATE
ON THE MATTER MISS MCCARTY.
WOULD NOT LIKE TO POSE. AT THE
FIRST ROLE BE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROAD. VERY LOW THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON A C. R. EIGHT. SMALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE IT.
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS ON A C.
R. EIGHT. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
AMERICA. THE WORK WILL. LOWS
THE ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE THERE
ARE SIXTY ONE CO AUTHORS ON A
C. R. EIGHT WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE WILL TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION ALL IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. ALL OPPOSED SAY NO.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED. MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THREE AB SEVENTY NINE THE CLERK
WILL READ SOME REAL SEVENTY
NINE BY SIMPLY RETURNING AN ACT
RELATING TO THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MR KING YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER A. B. SEVEN V. NINE IS.
ONE OF TEN BUDGET BILLS THAT WE
ARE PROPOSING TODAY. HAS ALL
THE LEGISLATORS KNOW THE
GOVERNOR HAS. REQUESTED THAT WE
TAKE EARLY ACTION ON A NUMBER
OF ITEMS IN THE HOUSE. THE
SENATE THE ASSEMBLY IN THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ARE IN
DISCUSSION ON WHICH ITEMS TO
TAKE. EARLY ACTION ON WE
DECIDED TO- FOR TEN BUILT
AROUND THAT WE FOR TEN BILLS TO
THE SENATE. FOR THEIR
CONSIDERATION AS WE GO INTO
BUDGET DELIBERATIONS. WE HAVE
TENTATIVELY SCHEDULED A HEARING
DATE FOR THE WEEK OF JANUARY
TWENTY FIFTH IN CASE THAT WE
MAY TAKE ACTION. SO JUST-
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON
A. B. SEVENTY NINE. AND THAT'S
THAT WE SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR
A BEES EIGHTY THROUGH EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MR CHANG MR.
FUNG YOU ARE RECOGNIZED ON THIS
MATTER. A MAN SPEAK TODAY I UP
TO THE EMPTY BUDGET BILL. THESE
AREN'T EVEN BILLS. THESE ARE
JUST NUMBERS WITH A SINGLE
SENTENCE. IT IS THE INTENT OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENACT
STATUTORY CHANGES RELATING TO
THE BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WE ARE BEGINNING TO CRAFT
THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE OF
PUBLIC POLICY WE WORK ON EACH
YEAR. AND WE ARE ALREADY
REVERTING TO THE UNFORTUNATE
COMMON PRACTICE OF THROWING
EMPTY BILLS INTO THE FRAY.
FAILING TO PROVIDE REAL BUDGET
TRANSPARENCY. YES BUT THIS BODY
ALONG WITH OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE SENATE. HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY TO LEAD
CALIFORNIA OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC. YET THESE EMPTY
VESSELS AND DO NOTHING TO PUT
US ON THE ROAD TO RECOVERY. WE
HAVE WORKING PARENTS WHO ARE
DESPERATELY WORRIED ABOUT THEIR
CHILDREN'S EDUCATION. STUDENTS
WHO WANT TO GO BACK TO SCHOOL
SAFELY. HOSPITALS THAT ARE
BEING CRUSHED WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES AND STAFF.
SMALL BUSINESSES TRYING TO
SURVIVE AND GET THEIR EMPLOYEES
BACK TO WORK. MAY ON MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS STOCK IN THE
BROKEN BUREAUCRACY OF THE ET
DE. FOREST MANAGEMENT PROJECTS
THAT NEED TO BE PRIORITIZED
PREVENT POWER SHUT OFFS. AND
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES AND THE
LIST GOES ON AND ON. THESE
PRESSING ISSUES AND MORE MUST
BE ADDRESSED IN THIS BUDGET.
BUT THE URGENCY WITH WHICH WE
MUST PROVIDE RELIEF TO THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. IS NO
EXCUSE TO CIRCUMVENT PROPER
PROCESS. AND UNDERMINE THE
TRANSPARENCY WE SHOULD PROVIDE.
THIS YEAR. THE BUDGET MEANS
MORE THAN EVER AND WE REVEAL
OUR PRIORITIES TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. WITH THE CREATION
OF THIS BUDGET BUT TODAY. ALL
WE HAVE TO SHOW OR ANTI BILLS.
WE SHOULD BE WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE STRUGGLING FAMILIES
SOMETHING TANGIBLE. BILLS OF
SUBSTANCE WITH THE REAL MEANS
OF RELIEF BEFORE WE CAST THE
VOTE. OF COURSE IT WILL BE SAID
THAT THIS IS THE WAY IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN DONE. BUT I WOULD
CHALLENGE US TO QUESTION THIS
REASONING. THESE ARE
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES AND
REQUIRES US TO REFLECT ON HOW
WE SHOULD SERVE THIS GREAT
STATE. ARISING OUT OF A
PANDEMIC. AND A RECESSION WE
SHOULD STRIVE TO CONNECT WITH
OUR CONSTITUENTS AND PROVIDE
THROUGH. HONEST TRANSPARENCY AS
YOU PASS THIS BUDGET. THESE
CHALLENGING TIMES SHOULD LEAD
ALL OF US TO FIND A BETTER
BUDGETING SYSTEM. WE NEED A
PROCESS THAT ENCOURAGES PUBLIC
INPUT STRENGTHENS THE INTEGRITY
TO THE LEGISLATURE AND MAXIMIZE
ITS TRANSPARENCY AND THAT'S WHY
I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO VOTE NO
ON THESE AND THESE ARE THE
BILLS TODAY. THANK YOU MR FUNG
WEST. THIRD TEAM HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE KING WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YES THINK ABOUT
SPEAKER JUST TO REITERATE TO
CALL- EVERY THROUGHOUT OUR
BUDGET PROCESS WE END UP
HAVING. HUNDREDS OF HEARINGS
THIS YEAR WOULD PROBABLY HAVE A
FEW LESS JUST BECAUSE OF.
BUILDING CONSTRAINTS BECAUSE OF
BUILDING CONSTRAINTS OF ROOM
CONSTRAINTS. WE HAVE AN
EXHAUSTIVE PROCESS THERE IS NO
COMMITTEE THAT DEBATES OR
DISCUSSIONS EVERY SINGLE ITEM.
MORE THAN OUR COMMITTEE I VERY
MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
ROBUST DISCUSSION. TO TALK
ABOUT WHAT IS IN THE BUDGET AS
WELL AS WELL WE WOULD BE.
FINALIZING THE BUDGET BUT IN
THE END WE HAVE FORTY MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE DESPERATE
FOR ACTION. IN SO THAT'S WHY WE
ARE TAKING THIS EARLY ACTION TO
LOOK OUT FOR THE MEDIATE. WITH
THAT THAT IS GOING TO BE.
WORKING ON SCHOOLS WHETHER IT'S
WORKING TO HELP SMALL
BUSINESSES. WEATHER IS TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS GET
MONEY THAT THEY DESPERATELY
NEED- THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
NEED ACTION AND WE'RE HERE TO
TAKE THANK YOU FOR SUBSCRIBING.
THANK YOU MR KING. THE CLERK
WILL OPEN THE ROLE. VERITABLE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED A- ALL
MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESERVE A.
ALL MEMBERS THOSE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLAND TALLY THE VOTE EYES
FORTY SIX KNOWS TWELVE. ENTER
PASSES. WITHOUT OBJECTION WE
WILL SUBSTITUTE THE ROLE FOR
ITEMS FOUR THROUGH TWELVE
EIGHTIES EIGHTY THROUGH EIGHTY
SEVEN INCLUSIVE THE CLERK WILL
READ. SOME OF THE- EIGHTY. FIVE
FORTY SIX NOTES WELL SOME AGO
EIGHTY ONE FIVE FORTY SIX NOTES
WELL SOME ABILITY TO I. FORTY
SIX NOTES WELL SOME AGO EIGHTY
THREE FIVE FORTY SIX NO TWELVE
SOME AGO EIGHTY FOUR FORTY SIX
YES WELL SOME AGO EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE FORTY SIX MOST WELCOME TO
GO EIGHTY SIX FIVE FORTY SIX
KNOWS WELL SOME AGO EIGHTY
SEVEN FIVE FORTY SIX YES WELL
INTO SOME ABILITY. FIVE FORTY
SIX KNOWS WELL. MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO THE SECOND DAY
CONSENT CALENDAR FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN. THERE IS A RESOLUTION
ON TODAY'S CONSENT CALENDAR
BEFORE WE VOTE ON THE CONTENT
CALENDAR WILL FIRST TAKE UP THE
RESOLUTION THAT IS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR PURPOSE OF
ADDING CO AUTHORS. WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE WILL TAKE ONE ROLL
CALL VOTE AND ALLOW ANY MEMBER
TO ADD ON AS A CO AUTHOR. TO
THAT RESOLUTION. THE CLERK READ
THE RESOLUTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE
AND OTHERS RELATIVE TO POSITIVE
PARENTING AWARENESS MONTH. THE
CLERK. WHEN I OPEN THE ROAD TO
ALLOW ANY. WHAT BUSINESS
REVENUE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRED. THIS VOTE IS. CO
AUTHOR ON THE CAN. HOW I
MEMBERS OF THE WHO VERY VOTE
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS. MA'AM
IF YOU WISH TO ADD YOUR NAME AS
A CO AUTHORED THIS RESOLUTION
PLEASE VOTE NOW. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE SIXTY
THREE CO AUTHORS. MOVING TO A
VOTE ON THE CONTENT CALENDAR
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN DOES ANY
MEMBER WISH TO MOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING ON THE CLERK
WILL READ THE SECOND ADVENT
CALENDAR. HOUSE RESOLUTION FOUR
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE
AND OTHERS RELATIVES POSITIVE
PARENTING AWARENESS MONTH THE
CLERK WILL OPEN A ROLLING AGAIN
THANK. ALL MEMBERS VOTED VERY
BOTH. ALONG MEMBERS THOSE WHO
DESERVE IT. WORK WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE AND TALLY THOSE I. SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS ADOPTED. IN THE
ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED MEMBERS. AND WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THEPREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
THE FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
THIS AGUILAR CURRY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY OF RICHARD ROMINGER A
RENOWNED MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMUNITY AND A LIFELONG FRIEND.
RICHARD ROMINGER WAS BORN IN
YOLO COUNTY AND BUILD HIS
ENTIRE LIFE HERE INCLUDING HIS
BELOVED FAMILY FARM HE WAS A
GENTLEMAN FARMER THROUGH AND
THROUGH. I MET RICH OVER SIXTY
YEARS AGO AS A CHILD AND
WINTERS CALIFORNIA. AFFILIATE
FOUND HIS HOME IN A SMALL TOWN
IN THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE EVELYN
WHILE ATTENDING UC DAVIS.
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE RICHES HAS
CONFUSED ME HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
INVALUABLE MENTOR. TO ME AND MY
FAMILY AND A PILLAR OF A TIGHT
KNIT COMMUNITY. EVERYONE KNOWS
THE ROOM INJURES AND THERE'S A
HISTORY ON THE FAMILY FARM WITH
RICH AND EVELYN AT THE CENTER
OF IT ALL. RIDGE IS IMMENSE
KNOWLEDGE AND PASSION FOR ALL
THINGS THAT CAUGHT THE
ATTENTION OF MANY FOREIGN WIDE.
WHICH WAS APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
JERRY BROWN AS THE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FOOD AND AGRICULTURE IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES. HE THEN
MOVED ON TO THE FEDERAL LEVEL
SERVING AS PART OF THE
PRESIDENT CLINTON'S
ADMINISTRATION AS THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY. OF THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF AGRICULTURE IN
WASHINGTON. RICH KNEW HOW TO
ADVOCATE FOR THE PLIGHT OF
FAMILY FARMERS HAVING STARTED
FARMING WITH THIS FAMILY AND
WITH HIS FATHER AND BROTHER.
AND NOW HANDING THE REINS TO
THEIR SONS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
KATHY AMERICAN THEY W. STA
SECRETARY DURING THE OBAMA
YEARS SAID THAT RICH MODELED
THE BEST OF AMERICAN
AGRICULTURE. BOTH ON THE FARM
AND IN THE HALLS OF POWER. NO I
WOULDN'T NEVER ONE TO FORGET
HIS ROOTS. RICH SPENT DECADES
ADVOCATING FOR THE CAUSES HE
MOST CARES ABOUT RIGHT HERE IN
OUR YELLOW COUNTY. HE WAS A CO
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT THE
YELLOW LAND TRUST CHAIRMAN OF
THE YELLOW COUNTY WATER
RESOURCES BOARD AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR MEMBER OF THE YELLOW
COUNTY AGRICULTURE ROUNDTABLE
STEERING COMMITTEE. THAT'S OUR
COUNTLESS OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
DEAR TO HIS HEART. IT WAS THE
ARDENT SUPPORTER OF HIS ALMA
MATER UC DAVIS AND HAVING BEEN
HONORED ALONG WITH HIS WIFE
EVELYN. WITH THE UC DAVIS METAL
IN NINETEEN AND IT IS A TWENTY
SIXTEEN FOR HIS SERVICE TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. HOLDS THE
COLLEGE OF AGRICULTURE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE. HIS TIME
WAS OUT ALSO AS A YOU REGENT
AND MORE. RICH WAS DIP DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO PRESERVING THE
LONGSTANDING TRADITION OF
FARMING AND AGRICULTURE IN HIS
FAMILY HIS COMMUNITY HIS STATE
IN THE COUNTRY. WE ARE ALSO
GRATEFUL FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND
LEGACY. I WILL TELL YOU THERE'S
MANY TIMES RICH WOULD GIVE ME A
CALL AND MAKE SURE I WAS DOING
THE RIGHT THING. ALWAYS WITH
AGRICULTURE AT THE FOREFRONT.
RICH ROMINGER WAS BORN IN
NINETEEN TWENTY SEVEN WOODLAND
CALIFORNIA AND PASSED
SURROUNDED BY HIS FAMILY IN
DECEMBER TWENTY TWENTY. RICHARD
IS SURVIVED BY HIS LOVELY WIFE
EVELYN HIS CHILDREN AND THEIR
SPOUSES RECKON PADDY RUTHANNE
LARS AND BRUCE AND ROBIN.
DAUGHTER IN LAW KAREN SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN AND A NEWBORN
GREAT GRANDSON. RICH'S LOST HIS
FELT ACROSS THE NATION
PARTICULARLY IN MY GREAT
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE WILL MISS YOU
RICH FOR YOUR WISDOM AND YOUR
FRIENDSHIP. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IN FACT ARE CURRY. MR RAMA
C. WERE RECOGNIZED FOR GERMAN
MEMORY OF MR MYERS. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER. IT IS WITH GREAT
SADNESS THAT ARISE- TODAY AS WE
ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF JOSEPH
MYERS. ASK AWAY ON DECEMBER
TWENTY NINTH AFTER A LONG
STRUGGLE WITH HEART RELATED
ISSUES. OUR CONDOLENCES GO OUT
TO HIS FAMILY HIS FRIENDS IN
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE NATION. ALL
OF WHOM LOST A GREAT ADVOCATE
AND A CHAMPION FOR JUSTICE. MR
MYERS WAS A POMO INDIANS HERE
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA A
CO FOUNDER OF THE NATIONAL
INDIAN JUSTICE CENTER AND
FOUNDER AND CHAIRMAN OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN MUSEUM AND
CULTURAL CENTER. MR MYERS LIVE
A LIFE OF COMMITMENT TO
JUSTICE. AND THE RULE OF LAW.
HE STARTED HIS CAREER AS A LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER IN THE CITY
OF OAKLAND. AND SERVED AS A
CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL
OFFICER BEFORE GOING ON TO
GRADUATE FROM UC BERKELEY'S.
LAWYER HE WORKED WITH AMERICAN
INDIAN LAWYER TRAINING PROGRAM
CALIFORNIA INDIAN LEGAL
SERVICES AND OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS. MR MYERS THROUGH
HIS DEDICATION SUCCESSFULLY
HELPED TO REVERSE THE
TERMINATION OF SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA INDIAN RANCHERIA
COMMUNITIES HERE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. HE ALSO WAS A
FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR NATIVE
AMERICAN CULTURE REPATRIATION
FOR REMAINS AND ARTIFACTS THIS
INCLUDED HELPING TO CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN MUSEUM AND
CULTURAL CENTER. IN ADDITION.
MR MYERS TODD. AT UC BERKELEY'S
DEPARTMENT OF ETHNIC STUDIES
OKEZIE ON NATIVE AMERICAN
ISSUES AND TEACHING CLASSES ON
FEDERAL INDIAN LAW AND TRIBAL
ISSUES THAT THIS LEGISLATURE
STILL DEBATES HERE TODAY IN
THIS CURRENT ATMOSPHERE. HE
RECEIVED NUMEROUS AWARDS AND
RECOGNITION THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE
FOR HIS WORK IN THE AREAS OF
LAW AND JUSTICE BUT ALSO. FOR
THE VIOLENCE PREVENTION ON
INDIAN RESERVATIONS. IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE HE
RECEIVED NATIONAL RECOGNITION
FROM THEN US ATTORNEY JANET
RENO. UC BERKELEY IS NOW HOME
TO JOSEPH A. MYERS CENTER FOR
RESEARCH ON NATIVE AMERICAN
ISSUES LOCATED IN THE
UNIVERSITY'S INSTITUTE. FOR
STUDY OF SOCIETAL ISSUES. MR
MYERS AND MYSELF GO BACK
PERSONALLY MANY YEARS MR MYERS
INVITED ME TO BE A KEYNOTE
SPEAKER AT UC BERKELEY AS THOSE
THAT WERE GRADUATING FROM BEING
THE LAWYER SCHOOL THAT'S THERE
THAT HE ACTUALLY CHAMPION TO
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
GETTING NATIVE AMERICANS-
ELECTED. FOR THE NATIVE
AMERICAN COMMUNITY HE'S VERY
MUCH A TRAILBLAZER. IN THE VERY
REASON WHY WE'RE SITTING IN THE
SEAT HERE TODAY. AND BRINGING
IT CLOSER TO HOME. ONE OF MY
FIRST INTERNS AS THE FIRST
CALIFORNIA INDIA LACKED IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE WAS HIS
GRANDDAUGHTER JAYDEN. JADEN
LAMB WHOSE MOTHER IS NIKKI
MYERS. SO EVEN THOUGH WE'VE
MOVED SO FAR. BEING THE FIRST
CALIFORNIA INDIAN ELECTED WAS
BECAUSE OF WHAT HE PUT OUT
THERE AND PAVE THE WAY FOR US
AND I AM HONORED. HONORED THAT
HIS GRANDDAUGHTER SERVED IN MY
OFFICE AS AN INTERN TO THAT WE
ALL JOSEPH MYERS IN THE MYERS
FAMILY A GREAT GRATITUDE FROM
INDIAN COUNTRY AND THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER THANK YOU MR AHMED. MR
SAY OUR TOE YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER.
OKAY THE SEVERITY WE WILL COME
BACK TO YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THIS AGUILAR CURRY
WERE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SMITH SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY. OF MY DEAR
TRUSTED FRIEND. FORMER CHAIRMAN
OF THE- TO THE HE WENT TO
NATION MARSHALL MCKAY. MARSHALL
MCKAY WAS AN ENERGETIC AND
VISIONARY LEADER FROM HIS TRIBE
BUT ALSO A GREAT DEFENDER OF
OTHER NATIVE PEOPLES AND
INDIGENOUS CULTURE. SERVING ON
THE BOARD OF THE NATIONAL
MUSEUM OF THE AMERICAN INDIAN
AND BECOMING THE FIRST AMERICAN
NATIVE CHAIR OF THE AUTRY
MUSEUM OF THE AMERICAN ROUSE
WEST. MARSHALL ALSO SERVED ON
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
HERITAGE COUNCIL AND COMMISSION.
SO THE- TODAY HE TRIBAL COUNCIL.
WE'LL MISS THE STRENGTH AND
WISDOM. HE WAS RESOLUTE
PROTECTOR OF NATIVE HERITAGE.
HERE WITHIN OUR HOMELAND BUT
ALSO THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA IN
INDIAN COUNTRY. I FIRST MET
MARSHALL IN MY JOB AS A PAYROLL
SYSTEMS ANALYST THE TRIBES FOR
SYSTEM WAS PURCHASED TO MANAGE
THEIR EMPLOYEES WHO WORK WITH
THE BINGO HALL ON TRIBAL LANDS
IN THE CAPE PAY VALLEY NEAR MY
HOME OF WINTERS. OVER HIS
THIRTY YEARS ON THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL THAT BINGO HALL BECAME
THE CACHE CREEK CASINO. HIS
VISION HIS LOVER THE LAND HIS
RESPECT FOR THE LAND. ALL CAME
TO FRUITION WHAT HE DID IN THE
KP VALLEY. AND THEN THERE WERE
THE HOTEL AND THE NEWEST IN THE
NEWS WHEN JUST OPENED THIS PAST
YEAR. YOU KNOW THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL MARSHALL BUILD AN
ECONOMY FOR YOUR TO DO YOU THE
DIVERSIFIED AND GREW. INCLUDING
A WORLD CLASS GOLF COURSE AND
MEETING FACILITY. AND ALL THE
AGRICULTURE INCLUDING SEKA
HILLS BRAND ONE OF THE WORLD'S
BEST OLIVE OILS AND WINDS. AND
AS THE PRIVATE ECONOMY GREW SO
DID MY FRIENDSHIP WITH HIM. IN
THE STANDING IN OUR REGION.
MARSHALL WAS NOT ONLY A STEWARD
OF THE COUNTRY'S NATIVE CULTURE.
HE WAS A GOOD FRIEND. HE WAS A
GOOD NEIGHBOR. HE IN THE TRIBAL
COUNCIL FUNDED HEALTH PUBLIC
SAFETY AND EDUCATION PROJECTS
IN COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT YOLO
COUNTY INCLUDING WINTERS. WHEN
I WAS THE MAYOR OF THE TRIBE
UNDER HIS LEADERSHIP HELP US
FUND A. GRADE SCHOOL TECHNOLOGY
INITIATIVE THE GATE TABLETS TO
CHILDREN. HE WENT AND THEY WERE
TRAINED THE PARENTS ARE TRAINED
THE TEACHERS RECLAIM TRAINED IT
OPENED A WHOLE NEW WORLD TO
WORKING FAMILIES IN MY TOWN.
I'LL NEVER FORGET WHEN HE CAME
TO THE KINDERGARTEN CLASS AND
SAT DOWN AND WATCHED THOSE
CHILDREN USE THE TABLETS FOR
THE FIRST TIME WITH THEIR
PARENTS. IN HIS HEART GOT BIG
THE SMILE ACROSS HIS FACE. AND
HE SAID WE'VE DONE GOOD. GERMAN
K. WAS BORN IN COLUSA. IN
NINETEEN FIFTY TWO. MARSHALL
THE SERVER SURVIVED BY HIS
LOVING WIFE SHARON ROGERS
MCKAY. HIS SON DYLAN THE STEPS
AND VANDOORNE BRENT. AND STEP
DAUGHTER SHOULD MAIL. AND THEIR
DAUGHTERS IN HER DAUGHTER'S US
DIDN'T. FIND CHINA SORRY. AND
HIS SISTER. HARRIET ROBERTS. MY
FRIEND MY MCKAY WILL BE SORELY
MISSED BY THE- TO DO HE MADE.
HEALTH INDIAN COUNTRY AND BY ME.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISS
AGUILAR CURRY RESTAURANTS YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THIS GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
I RISE ALSO AS THE- CALIFORNIA
INDIAN ELECTED HERE IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF THE SPEAKER OF THIS
ASSEMBLY OFFERING OUR- REGARDS
TO THE FAMILY. MARTIAL MCKAY
CHAIRMAN MCKAY IS A PERSONAL
FRIEND THAT WE GREW UP- ALONG
THE WAY WITH ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT THAT- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF BLACK CURRY SO
ELOQUENTLY DESCRIBED IT GOES
BACK INTO THE DAYS BEFORE
PEOPLE EVEN KNEW THE TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS EXISTED WITHIN
THEIR COMMUNITIES LET ALONE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. MARSHALL
PAVE THE WAY PAVE THE WAY BY
ESTABLISHING BEING ONE OF THE
FIRST- CHAIRMAN OF THEN CALLED
CALIFORNIA NEVADA INDIAN GAMING
ASSOCIATION THAT NOW BEARS. THE
NAME OF C. NIAGARA THAT WE ALL
KNOW. GERMAN MCKAY. AND US HEY
THE WAY AND BIG TO LOBBY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. FOR THE
RIGHT TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
GAMING. MAKING SURE THAT THOSE
CONTACTS DID MOVE FORWARD.
CHAIRMAN MCKAY WAS A- PATH IN
THE TRAILBLAZER TO LEAD THE WAY
NOT ONLY FOR THE YOUNGSTER HE
PEOPLE BUT FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE REST OF THE
NATION. HE CONTINUED TO OPEN
THOSE DOORS CONTINUE TO LOBBY
AND TELL WE GOT THOSE CONTACTS
AND THE RIGHT TO GOVERN A TRUE
CHAMPION OF TRIBAL SOVEREIGNTY.
WE CONTINUE TO LIVE WITHIN THAT
SOVEREIGNTY IN THE MISSION THAT
HE SET OUT TO DO HERE TODAY
WITH SO MANY TRIBES ENGAGED IN
THE ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
SUCCESS. BUT MARSHALL ALSO KNEW
THAT THAT WASN'T ALL THAT MATE
WHO WE ARE AS CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE. AS MARSHALL CONTINUED
TO MOVE FORWARD ON EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT. EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT WITHIN THE TRIBAL
INDIAN COMMUNITY MARSHALL MOVED
FORWARD ON AN IDEA TO MOVE AND
CREATE THE FIRST TRIBAL COLLEGE
I'M HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THAT WOULD BRING
TRIBES. TOGETHER BUT HE ALSO.
WAS REAL A TEACHER OF THE
CULTURE AND THE ARTS WITH THE
LOCAL SCHOOLS. WITH THE PEOPLE
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE IF ALL
YOU SEE NOW. IS GAMING THEN
YOU'RE MISSING THE WHOLE
PICTURE OF WHO WE ARE. MARSHALL
MCKAY CHAIRMAN MCKAY. IS A
GREAT ADVOCATE AND MOVING THOSE
ISSUES FORWARD. SO MUCH SO THAT
AS OUR ROADS CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD WE ENDED UP BACK ON THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. AND IT'S ONLY
FITTING THAT WE MENTIONED THE
TWO TRAILBLAZERS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY WITH
CHAIRMAN MCKAY AND JOSEPH
MYERS. ARE ROAD STARTED OFF
EARLY IN LIFE BUT WE ALL CAME
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN UP
UNTIL WE'RE ABLE TO CHAIR THE
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE
COMMISSION. WERE MARSHALL SAT
ON THERE AS A COMMISSIONER
ASSORTED JOSEPH MYERS. GERMAN
MCKAY WAS ONE THAT WOULD ALWAYS
BE SUPPORTIVE AND MOVING
FORWARD TO ONE DAY GET SOMEONE
ELECTED AND IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. HE WAS SOMEONE
THAT SHOWED MENTORING AND
SUPPORT FOR US MOVING FORWARD
TO BE ABLE TO SIT IN THIS
CAPITAL HERE TODAY. IF IT
WASN'T FOR THAT SUPPORT AND FOR
HIM LAYING THE WAY FOR SO MANY
OF US. NOT JUST HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE UNITED STATES.
THEN A LOT OF US WITNESS FIRE
TO BE WHERE WE'RE AT TODAY.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT MENTORING IT
REALLY IS ABOUT SOMEONE THAT
YOU SEEN PAVE THE WAY. THAT
LOOKS LIKE. AND DRESSES LIKE
YOU AND UNDERSTANDS THE CULTURE
THAT MAKES SOMEONE MOVE FORWARD
BECAUSE AFTER ALL JUST NEEDS
SOMEONE TO BELIEVE IN WHAT IT
IS YOU'RE DOING. AND CHAIRMAN
MCKAY WAS THAT SOMEONE THAT
BELIEVED IN SO MANY OF US
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA I WANNA THANK YOU
AND THE SPEAKER OF AN ASSEMBLY
OF WOMEN ACQUIRE CURRY FOR
RECOGNIZING THAT. AND TOGETHER
WE WILL HONOR ALWAYS HONOR
CHAIRMAN MCKAY IN OUR THOUGHTS
AND PRAYERS THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER. THANK YOU MR AHMED. MR
THATCHER YOU RECKONER THE REAL
CHAMBER YOUR TERM MEMORY. THANK
YOU MADAM. MEMBERS I RISE TO
ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN MEMORY
OF DR STANDS HERE FORMER
SUPERINTENDENT OF THE MYRIAD OF
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
DR SURE DEVOTED HIS LIFE TO
PUBLIC EDUCATION. SERVING OVER
FIFTY YEARS OF HIS CAREER FIRST
AS A CLASSROOM TEACHER THEN AS
AN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL PRINCIPAL.
AND ULTIMATELY AS A
SUPERINTENDENT IT IS A POSITION
THAT HE HELD IN FOUR DIFFERENT
DISTRICTS IN THREE DIFFERENT
STATES. AFTER SERVING IN THE U.
S. ARMY FOR TWO YEARS DR HERE
BECAME THE FIRST IN HIS FAMILY
TO GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE.
EARNING HIS DOCTORATE IN SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATION FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF WYOMING. AND
COMPLETING SOME POST DOCTORATE
COURSE WORK AT HARVARD GRADUATE
SCHOOL. DR SHEARER SERVED AS
SUPERINTENDENT OF MARIETTA
VALLEY HIGH SCHOOL I MEAN. AT A
VALUE TO FIGHT SCHOOL DISTRICT
FROM 200-062-2000 TWELVE WHERE
HE LED THE DISTRICT THROUGH
SOME YEARS OF EXTREME GROWTH.
AND THE ADDITION OF DOROTHY
MAGLI MIDDLE SCHOOL HAD A MESA
HIGH SCHOOL AND LISA J. MAILS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL ALL THIS
DESPITE DIFFICULT FINANCIAL
TIMES FOR THE STATE. DOCTORS
WAS A COMPASSIONATE AND
DEDICATED LEADER AND EDUCATOR
COMMITTED TO STUDENT LEARNING.
HE COULD BE FOUND AND MANY OF
THE DISTRICT EVENTS WHERE THE
KIDS WERE PERFORMING EITHER IN
CONCERTS OR IN THEIR ATHLETIC
ENDEAVORS. NOT ONLY WORK TO
INSPIRE STUDENTS TO LEARN AND
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS. HE ALSO
ATTRACTED AND IT'S INSPIRED
OTHER TEACHERS TO REACH THEIR
OWN FULL POTENTIAL AS MENTORS.
HE WAS A MAN OF FAITH AND
CONVICTION WHO ONCE DESCRIBED
EDUCATORS AS TRULY THE KEEPERS
OF THE DREAM FOR THE CHILDREN
WHO COME TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY.
WITH THEIR INDIVIDUAL HOPES AND
ASPIRATIONS. HE RETIRED FROM
PUBLIC EDUCATION IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TO SPEND MORE
TIME WITH HIS FAMILY IN
LOVELAND COLORADO. SADLY ON
DECEMBER THIRTEENTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY DOCTORS HERE
PASSED AWAY DUE TO
COPLICATIONS BUT THE RESULTING
FROM. PROBATE NINETEEN. JUST
DAYS BEFORE ON DECEMBER SEVENTH
DR SHARES WONDERFUL WIFE
MARIANNE ALSO SUCCUMBED TO THIS
INSIDIOUS VIRUS. THEY LEAVE
BEHIND FIVE CHILDREN AND
THIRTEEN GRANDCHILDREN. IN HIS
WAKE DR SHEARER HAS LEFT A
LASTING LEGACY OF LEADERSHIP
AND COMPASSION IN MARIETTA.
MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AN
ASSET WE ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF SUPERINTENDENT DR
STAN SCHEER. THANK YOU MR
FARIBAULT. MISTER MEDINA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER PURE GERMAN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE
TO ADJOURN THE MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND PROFESSOR AND NEIGHBOR
DR ELUDE MARTINEZ. DR MARTINEZ
PASSED ON FRIDAY DECEMBER
EIGHTEENTH SURROUNDED BY HIS
LOVING FAMILY. HE WAS BORN IN
TEXAS ON THE TWENTY FIRST OF
JANUARY. NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE
AND WAS THE ELDEST OF SIX
CHILDREN. ELUDE SERVING THE
UNITED STATES MARINE CORPS.
ENROLLED IN GRADUATE WORK AT
MEXICO'S NATIONAL UNIVERSITY.
AND RECEIVED HIS PHD AT OHIO
UNIVERSITY. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO ELUDE BEGAN TEACHING AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE IN THE COMPARATIVE
LITERATURE PROGRAM AND SERVED
AS THE PROGRAM'S COORDINATOR. A
SPECIALIST IN THE NARRATIVE
CYCLE OF THE MEXICAN RED
REVOLUTION WITH A SPECIAL FOCUS
ON MARIANO A SWEATER. ELUDE
PUBLISHED THE ART OF MAIDANA'S
WELL. MODERNISM IN RAMALLAH
ORDER IN TEN YEARS LATER
PUBLISHED VOICE HAUNTED JOURNEY
SEMI ARE. NOVEL THE TRACES AS
MAIN CHARACTERS LIVE IN A
RACIALLY SEGREGATED TEXAS.
AMONG HIS OTHER PUBLICATIONS
AND NUMEROUS ARTICLES. ON
CHICANO AND MEXICAN LITERATURE.
ELUDE HAD A HEART AND
IMAGINATION AS BIG AS THE STATE
OF TEXAS WITH INTEREST IN
CHICANA AND CHICANO POETRY
NARRATIVE CINEMA HISTORY AND
PAINTING. HIS READERS
COLLEAGUES AND FRIENDS WILL
NEVER FORGET HIM. ELUDE IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE LISA
MARTINEZ HIS DAUGHTERS LAURA
MARTINEZ MCDERMOTT TANYA
MARTINEZ BELOW SO AND
GRANDCHILDREN MITCHELL
MCDERMOTT MY NIECE A MCDERMOTT
MADELINE MCDERMOTT. MIA
MCDERMOTT AND WOLFGANG BELOW SO
I ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN THE
MEMORY OF DR THE LEWD MARTINEZ
THANK YOU MR MENDIETA MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES THE
DEATH BE PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
ALL REQUESTS TO JOURNEY MEMORY
WILL BE DEEMED TO READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL. MOVING
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS PLEASE
NOTE THE JANUARY TWENTY SECOND
IS THE DEADLINE TO SUBMIT
LANGUAGE REQUESTS TO
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL THE SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS MONDAY
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH IS. MARTIN
LUTHER KING JUNIOR DAY. TUESDAY
JANUARY NINTH- HAVE FOR SUCH AT
ONE. ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING
PASS TO RETAIN ON THE SHALL BE
CAN. C. AND HEARING NO BIDS I'M
READY TO ENTERTAIN MOTION OR-
MR MONTANA IN MYSTERY SECOND AT
THIS AND INTO TUESDAY JANUARY.
AT ONE PM.